[Music]
what's up guys today we are going to be
trying chinese candy and this is like
candy i grew up with a super nostalgic
for me and tiff's always trying mexican
candy and she's buying them and an
interesting having you try yeah having
me try yeah because i'm like i've tried
them yeah and i never returned the
flavor
[Music]
the flavor but yeah so today i'm gonna
introduce tiff to some chinese candies
oh and our little baby yeah you know
what i don't know what's wrong i never
crave sweets like i never do but
recently i've been craving sweets maybe
it's like that whole like your sympathy
pregnancy symptoms yeah and i'm like
getting cravings and i'm craving
specifically chinese candy i actually
opened the box of the lychee jellies
here and i got a woof of it
a whiff of it
man
like you have pregnancy brain
but yeah i got a whiff of the lychee
jellies in like like the summer 2000
came back for me oh you remember the
specific year specifically these were
hidden in our household during the 2000
olympics
we're watching the olympics it's cute
and we're and we're eating these summer
olympics yeah they would they have to be
cold these aren't cold but um
it's better
now these are fresh out of the package i
don't even know the names of these
candies honestly i just found i was like
oh that that's what it looks like oh
yeah by the way huge shout out to anchor
for sponsoring today's video i'm
actually charging my phone with their
charger in case you don't know what
anker is anker is the leading fast
charging brand with over 65 million
users around the world so recently i've
been using their anker nanopro to charge
my phone anchor is actually really good
at charging phones like they actually
charge faster
it's like super fast it's not just for
phones either because they the one that
we currently have it has a usbc port to
it and i have some earbuds that have a
usbc plug in order to charge it and the
anker nano pro charges so freaking fast
it can charge your iphone 12 from zero
to 50 percent in just 26 minutes yeah
that's like three times faster than the
original apple charger it's 50 smaller
than the iphone charger the anchor nano
pro provides more power while saving
space in your bag or while charging and
you know some crevice in your home but
the best part yet is that it monitors
the temperature of your phone while it's
charging so that it won't overheat yeah
so we highly recommend the anker nanopro
if you're looking for a better way to
charge your iphone faster make sure to
check them out in the link in the
description down below now let's get
into these candies yeah you know what i
said i was gonna look up the names of
the the candies i realize there's
english on these candies now too
so
we know the name of the candy what's
this one oh it's a lucky candy oh this
is lucky yeah it's very fitting it's
like chinese people are really into like
auspiciousness
yeah i think that's the chinese so this
is a candy that i think people eat
during chinese new year yeah
specifically
interesting wanna start with that one i
guess you would create the palette since
you know what they're like you create
the palette for me to try in that case
we should go with hot flakes
half lake you know it looks like
firecrackers
it does it looks like it's supposed to
have a little wick thing or fuse thingy
and light it and then run away i haven't
eaten these in so long that i don't even
remember what it tastes like
hot okay because that's an ingredient i
thought it was just the name of the
brand but
is short for a hawthorn and which is
uh the name of a fruit hawthorne fruit
oh i've never heard of that yeah and
it's a really popular like chinese
people put it on a stick like they
skewer hawthorne fruits it's like in a
row and then they like dip it in some
sugar and then that's like an actual
like street candy
they're little discs yeah these kind of
remind me of my own blast the ones that
i was giving you recently remember the
little paper paper candies oh yeah yeah
except i think these pack way more
flavor though than those ones they smell
really good cheers
oh my my thinking it's single hmm very
tart
right this tastes like somebody there's
like they're like the tamarindo flavor
and mexican candy reminds me of how
chinese candy tastes like it they're oh
my god these are so good they're like
distant clothes
yeah you know put some tahini on this
i'm telling you no not tahini no or um
that was about six for yours no it's all
fanned out a lot of you never shared
this with me
what we've been together for almost 10
years i'm not a candy person but when i
get into my cravings though so yummy oh
man these are actually way better than i
remember them i used to like them
because they did they were just fun to
play with and like flavor flavor-wise
it's like whatever
because it's not
what
because i'm like oh this is whatever
because these delicious these aren't
that sweet you know what i mean
yeah i'm like give me that kick you know
give me something these are more sweet
i think so yeah like i i would say
that's why i started with this because
these are kind of like light but they're
really so glad you might like the big
packets of these baby do you like it
these are so good i'm like shocked i
genuinely was like
we'll see i don't know you weren't
expecting much from chinese candy no he
wasn't you're so good all right what's
next let's try something very
traditional okay and we know it's
traditional because it's like it says
chinese traditional yeah across the
whole thing oh fruits chinese
traditional fruits this is a whole ass
fruit actually like like if you open it
it's a whole aspect of reserved
uh plum i really like this paper though
it feels like pressure down traditional
still nostalgic like in the 1930s they
had the same packaging this probably
existed since the 1930s do people wrap
the stuff by hand because it looks like
it's done by hand
oh this looks like somebody though right
it does oh but it does not smell like
that though really so it doesn't look
the best this is uh so this is what is
it
traditional plum yeah but it doesn't
look the best you know and not very
appetizing looking but it doesn't smell
the best
yeah it's true my opinion honestly when
i was a kid i don't think i was a fan of
these these these this is like old
people candies you know what i mean this
is like grandpa when you do this you
know eat it now yeah
i'm like stop talking i want to try it
oh and there's a seed in the middle be
careful with that
it does taste like medicine
not a big fan you put the whole thing in
your mouth it's a lot
mesh tangy you like tangy it's not bad i
wouldn't think it's bad but i wouldn't
reach out for these like i wouldn't like
out of all these i'd be like i'll save
this for last
that's a good way to put it i think the
flavor is better than what it smells
like though i think it's just the smell
that makes me think of medicine more
than the flavor it has a licorice kind
of vibe to it but very small hip and
then it's more like tamarindo yeah
it's like a little like spice elements
like black licorice
yeah i know you mean there's definitely
some old people handicappers and now you
have to spit things out like young
people don't like doing this
i have a tiny seed how big is yours i
don't know i'm eating around it and it
just feels big
i think mine is bigger than earth oh
yeah that's true you didn't clean it
very well oh my gosh
[Laughter]
because you always say that with bung i
don't you didn't clean the bone well
enough i'm like i did my best okay
no you did good you did good all right
so what is next
tell me sir
plum candy yeah so these
is uh
these is
these is called uh in chinese
yeah yeah
but this is a woman that is like coated
in a candy like a hard candy this is not
suitable for children under six years
old
baby you can't eat this oh no
probably because it's a choking hazard
yeah these are my one of my favorites
just because it has a dual taste the
sweet on the outside is like really
sweet and like once you get to the
center oh wow
there's two flavors to this there's the
plum which is like salty and uh tangy
really sticky and then the candy itself
is really sweet it's like a do do double
flavor cheers don't get stuck together
no
oh pretty hard
[Music]
oh i suck in my food you're not saying
big enough for this this is huge i don't
have to spit it out oh wait you need the
flavor
the candy the hard part tastes like
butterscotch i like the hints of the
plum
like the saltiness right it's a nice
little like getting both flavors at the
same time
there's definitely mexican candies are
kind of like this
oh
you're biting candy oh it hurts my teeth
don't you eat ice cream
when i chew into like hard candy like
that i just think of like all the
cavities my teeth are getting this is
good but just for the purpose of moving
on i'm gonna spit it out
i like it though i just want to soak on
the plum part
good i'm not really a big fan of the
hard candy one
it's a little too
yellow number one number seven or
whatever what what number is this
there's a yellow number six it's two
yellow number six
okay which one's next
let's get um let's get to your favorite
one the right rabbit rabbit all right so
the article that i found like this list
the baby likes oh yeah it already knows
the interesting thing about this white
rabbit thing well there's a couple of
interesting things one there's a history
lesson in this before the cultural
revolution in china before the
communists took over white rabbit used
to be i guess
white
mouse
yeah you already know you already know
it used to be a white mouse i guess
because there used to be a mouse on here
but the government thought that having a
mouse on there might be a little too
disney-ish like and
they don't want no foreign uh influence
whatsoever so they changed it to a
rabbit so that's interesting thing
number one interesting thing number two
is tip you already found it and you've
started eating the wrapper there's a
paper wrapper and then there is a
secondary wrapper what is that made of
rice paper
yeah so you're supposed to eat it with
this wrapper which as a kid i wasn't a
really big fan of now i'm like oh it's a
texture thing but as a kid i was like it
tastes like nothing well the fun part is
it dissolves
let's play with that
oh
my
god oh yeah yeah it's like a wannabe
chewy candy but it really isn't it's
still kind of hard it's like a taffy
mm-hmm
it's kind of like a like a really really
hard rice flavored tootsie roll
it's a milk candy
i was trying to figure out what the
flavor was i just wanted rice because
i'm like it's something white
i thought it was interesting that this
was a milk flavored candy when in china
we don't eat anything with milk here's
like a meeting i'm like eating i'm
eating whole milk that's sweetened
mm-hmm
which is really really good
yeah i just wish it was like a better
texture
you finished yours
how i just chewed through it i can't
it's just
all these muscles look at that
these jaw muscles you're flexing your
jump oh my god they're so hard
all right i'm gonna do uh take a break
from chewing yeah yeah i mean yeah
i wasn't really chewing
all right lychee jelly lighty jelly so
these are really shots all right so
these are relatively new because these
became a thing within my lifetime these
things came like became a craze in like
the early 2000s like maybe late 90s
early 2000s doesn't that make you feel
old like when you remember when
something was new
and popular and brand new so it's
basically a gelatin
with some juices in there and little
bits of like lychee all right so it's
like a little jello shot literally
yeah so the way to eat it so it's kind
of got like little grooves on the sides
you just pinch it
oh cool
i mean it pops up that is so cool okay
and then and we cheers cheers and
you're so fun to eat
my family we'd like to borrow one of
these
tubs in like two nights how does this
fit in a child's mouth oh
there were a lot of news reports about
uh kids not being allowed to eat these
these kids were suffocating they were
like they're eating them and it'll get
caught in their throat and they couldn't
like get it out oh god kids would die
eating these what
they still sell them yeah you would
think they'd be like oh yeah let's make
them smaller yeah
they're like you know what i think these
might be smaller really these were bomb
but i'm really just shocked at the fact
that they're just so huge like they
should make them a little shallower wait
till you try them when they're chilled
that sounds delicious all right that
should be a staple in this household in
the summer oh because for mexican
households we have bullies and i'll
break out the lychee jellies here we go
there we go baby we're planning out your
future mexican chinese heritage and
isaac can finally get some chinese in
his life get some like be cultured your
culture is what i'm talking about so we
have two left we have two left yeah
which one would you like so i i'm
assuming one you're gonna absolutely
love and one you're gonna absolutely
hate so it's ginger candy and lucky
candy well i don't even know what's in
this but i know this is ginger i like
ginger it's spicy but i don't know it
might be a little too crazy yeah i think
like chinese people i think i've tried
this too in hong kong i think you might
your mom gave me one of these before i
know i didn't like these when i was a
kid when i was a kid i was like these
things are too intense
who would eat this okay
oh they're white
they didn't look like this before
this jelly filled does it look like
jelly filling yeah
they weren't before what were they
before i don't remember oh my god
the shape on the outside looks the same
it looks like it's like jelly filled
look i think it is because it looks pink
yeah inside but it's white on the
outside or maybe it's always been jelly
filled and i just never pay attention
that does sound like you i'm also the
kind of kid that would just have it and
i'd be like
and eat it and just never see the inside
yeah i would just never see the inside
of it
oh my god oh yeah it brings me back
tastes the same i feel like it tasted a
candy that tastes like this before but
not this kind
i have no idea what the flavor is though
yeah what is that it tastes like
strawberries to you
maybe
i know you know how i always say you you
smell like melted strawberry ice cream
yeah and fish flavor
so i've always been lucky to you
you're lucky
let me try fighting
no i can't do it oh my god
[Music]
oh it's pink inside maybe it is
strawberry it's pink this might be like
thai for me
really mm-hmm i actually beat out white
rabbit i did why why was i too subtle
yeah you're right it's kind of hard to
eat yeah this is this is a very subtle
flavor it's more subtle than i remember
it and these are easier to eat and like
more
packed with flavor oh you like it enough
not to spit it out that's how you know
to like it
usually i'll spit it out time for the
last one our least favorite one
your least favorite my least favorite
because i don't remember
hating it that much or maybe
i hated it as a kid because i just
didn't understand why anyone would
appreciate this flavor ginger candy oh
it's squishy yeah oh then this isn't
something i've tried then
mmm larger texture texture
it is spicy not too bad
it's getting spicier yeah i feel like
this is the perfect candy for me to eat
when i lose my voice
oh yeah that's spicy it's like um you
know there's canada dry ginger rail
and then there's like the more like
artisanal ginger ale ginger beer and
they're like spicy mm-hmm that's just
candy yeah this would be definitely a
candy this one and this
i'm eating these when i'm sick
yeah
old people candy oh people candy these
are the ones these something for the
kids mm-hmm and this is for when i just
want like a a refreshing
even though it's creamy like for some
reason i want to put the word refreshing
with it this is the refreshing one oh
yeah yeah and then this
i probably wouldn't eat this okay
i actually really like that one i think
out of all these this is my least
favorite i would even i would eat this
over this i just really don't like the
the hard candy flavor i would actually
put this ginger candy yeah you know what
i actually really like this like i'm an
old man now
i actually really like these ginger
second one yeah it's really really good
it's kind of addicting i like the spice
mm-hmm yeah this is the most sugar i've
had in a long time yeah i'm looking for
my uh gestational diabetes test pretty
soon so let me get back oh yeah
[Music]
actually it was a good thing that i spit
out all these canteens and finish it oh
there you go well for the next one of
these if we do another candy video let's
do a mexican one yes i already have an
entire list of candies like once you
told me we're doing this video i'm like
don't even trip i got all my mexican
stuff i have mexican candy categorized
in different flavors
i have different types of like mexican
drinks mexican um like breads like
bakery bread desserts i'm gonna do a
chinese drink one veda soy
that's chinese i think so chrysanthemum
tea
yeah those are good it's like all
healthy stuff
yeah and then even like mexican chips oh
and then shrimp chips and then like
categorizing the chips into like spicy
um
i don't even know what else right now
yeah i think you have way more firepower
than what i'm aware of from my chinese
library of snacks and drinks anyways
thanks for watching today's video i am
really hopped up on sugar now so
we getting lucky
yeah this is really fun i i want to do
more of these videos let us know if you
enjoyed this type of video if you guys
are looking forward to the mexican
version of this because that's just fun
stuff right there i love it just trying
stuff from your your culture and then
you try and suffer my culture and then
we can expand and try things from other
people's cultures that'd be tight but
yeah if you guys have tried these
candies let me know which one is your
favorite and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]